huge story right now there's been a lot
of crazy revelations about Trump's
personal attorney in the news Michael
Cohen a lot of people talking about that
guy
Cohen became famous for arranging a hush
money payment to a porn actress who
claimed she'd had an affair with Donald
Trump well more recently the FBI raided
Cohen's home and office as you all know
well just yesterday in court a judge
forced Cohen to disclose that he also
performed services for Fox host Sean
Hannity man it keeps getting crazier and
crazier with this guy well at least it's
all out in the open now and we all know
who all is skeevy clients are well
that's just it Andy we don't know about
all of his clients I have a feeling and
a lot of people have a feeling we may
very soon find out about other people
Michael Cohen did dirty favors for what
do you mean I thought Michael Cohen just
had those three clients I mean nobody
said anything about warnings see now
that the FBI has confiscated all the
guy's files I'm sure many of Cohen's
other clients will be exposed for the
horny creeps
they really are it's just a matter of
time yeah but no one cares about those
other guys right I mean I'm sure Conan
has a lot of legitimate clients too good
guys no no Andy not this guy
Cohen is what's known as a fixer he
makes problems go away for wealthy men
who all have a disgusting shameful
secret to hide if I ever worked with
Michael Cohen I'd be very very nervous
right now
very nervous were you called nervous
and
all I'm saying is the FBI has all of
Cohen's personal data his smartphone his
laptop
you got me sure lotta dirts gonna shake
loosen mark my words more of these
weasels are gonna go down they're gonna
go down hard Andy oh dear god I hate me
[Applause]
any what are you doing you don't smoke
you don't know what I'm capable of
oh I know Andy all I know is that if I
had some scuzzy connection to Michael
Cohen I'd make damn sure nobody
recognized me in public
I'd be figuring out how to get the hell
out of town that's what I'd be doing
keep it together Rick look at yourself
be honest are you one of Michael Cohen's
clients huh
no god no I just told my cousin I'd go
cher one-woman show it's a multimedia
performance art thing about her
dysfunctional relationship with gluten
I've been trying to get out of it so if
you don't mind for the next six months
can you just call me Rick Lawson no no
Andy that sounds like it's a really bad
I mean this one well that's what that
one-woman show sounds awful
oh you have no idea it's called dreaming
with my eyes open an Imagi wakening it's
two and a half hours long and she does
an entire rap song about her gut
bacteria oh and don't get mad at me but
I told my cousin I bring you to Conan
who's Conan
please please Andy my name is Damien Ron
tree and I think we have a great show
tonight
[Applause]
you